this is jocko podcast number 287
with echo charles and me jonco willing
good evening echo good evening and
joining us again is dave burke good
evening dave good evening
so listen if you've been tracking
we have been talking about bh liddell
hart we've been talking about his
strategy of the indirect approach we've
been covering his book the strategy of
indirect approach
then we rolled into his book which is
just called strategy
this stuff is
it is just it it's it's so important to
wrap your head around this stuff it's a
lot of it is
counterintuitive when you hear it it's
it's counterintuitive when you hear it
it's sometimes even more
counter-intuitive when you try and
do it and if you
understand it and you do it and you
execute it
it is a game changer in the way you
execute
and it's also a game changer in the way
you think so if you haven't yet
listened to 285 and 286 to learn a
little bit about
bh libel heart who he is
you know a a veteran a soldier a british
soldier
world war one wounded multiple times
sent back from the front multiple times
sent back to the front multiple times
fought in the battle of the psalm i mean
just
almost this whole battalion wiped out
gravely wounded with gat he was gassed i
mean
been to hell and back quite literally
and
there's not too many people we can talk
about obviously that fought in the
battle of psalm
and and on the last podcast i was
talking about the fact that he
you know battle you know we throw the
words battle tested around like all this
battle tested
how about battle tested in what's
actually the worst
battle ever that's where he kind of
started to think about the strategy and
tactics that were being used this is
what sort of when he talks about the
indirect approach
is the antithesis to what world war one
was so if you haven't yet go back and
listen to 285
and 286 and then join us
right now with 287 dave
any intro remarks no matter what you
were writing down
[Applause]
thinking about the last podcast that we
did
and just where he's coming from and i'm
actually super stoked to get to
these concluding these the end of this
section or this this
this trilogy um
because i was saying this last time i
think
this is all new like i get to hear this
in real time
and the sort of the chronology of your
very first introduction from 285 was
like hey a little bit of the background
of heart but i didn't really
it didn't really sink in as you were
saying it of
what you just said like what he went
through
and you said it left a mark on him but i
don't
i did not i did not appreciate the depth
of that mark and
what it compelled him to do to try to
course correct this massive
this this massive mistake that that he
had to endure in witness
so i i have
i think i've been able to understand
what he's been saying a lot better as
you've been reading it thinking about
where he came from you know what i
should have done is
i should have gone well first of all i
should have given a little bit more
detail there
but i also should have gone back there's
so many references to bh la del hart in
so many
manuals it's ridiculous and i should
have pulled some of those up and said oh
when we did this
marine corps manual when i did this army
manual here's where this come from
here's the roots of the statement
because they
they cite they cite him so
i guess part of it is there's some other
podcasts that i have
in the hopper in my mind that i want to
do that i really
can't do without people understanding
this idea of the strategy of the
indirect approach i just can't
i can't go forward it's like i had to do
this so
i will go back i'm sure and do some more
historical context
around his life and what he went through
but i also man i wanted to get this
stuff out there you know it's like a
prioritize and execute drill to be quite
frank with you
i would i wanted to get people to
understand this and
and see how beneficial it can be
for their thought process because it's
been so beneficial for my
for the last 30 years of my life uh
maybe 20
25 years of my life where i realized
wait a second
going direct isn't always the best thing
in fact the more i
figured that out the more i was like oh
going direct is usually not the best
thing
quite often the indirect approach is
correct
it's the correct thing in jiu jitsu it's
the correct thing in battlefield it's a
correct thing as a leader
it's a correct thing interacting with
other human beings
so that's kind of where we uh
how we got here you know a lot that's
the weird thing about uh
having a podcast and doing things via
podcast is
part of the benefit of it is the
immediacy of it
right like there's not you know if you
write a book if i was to write a book
about this stuff
it would take three years now two years
like if i just was gave up everything
else and said i'm gonna write a book
about this it would take
two years to do to get it to get it
written to get it published to get it or
started get it written edit it like
there's so much lag time to do a podcast
it's like cool
you know what here's a book i've had
this book for a long time i actually
gave you my extra copy of this book
so to be able to say you know what
i want to get this done now's the time
boom you can go and execute it
and it's and what you sacrifice is you
sacrifice
some perfection right you sacrifice some
perfection because
head i sat there and thought about the
best way to do this maybe i would have
said you know what i need a
i need an entire episode about the
battle of the psalm i need an entire
episode about
what gassing does to you i need to do an
episode about his battalion
with the yorkshire light regiment right
and talk about exactly who's in there
there's a whole bunch of different
things i could have done
and and it's not and that's that would
have made this better
and that's one of the one of the
compromises that you make
in moving forward and executing like you
know what i'm looking back now hindsight
20 20. cool should have done that didn't
do it we'll do it in the future
the way it goes yeah and even for me as
i
as i contemplate what i'm trying to say
you talk about you sacrifice the
perfection of your sacrifice
even the way i'm trying to say what i'm
thinking is not exactly right it's not
how i would
say it if i spent time to sit down with
a pen and paper and write out
what i'm thinking or what i'm thinking
about or the references i'm making in my
head
but to be able to sort of reflect in
real time
as you're reading this as inaccurate or
not as eloquent as i'd like it to be
it's a really cool exercise as a
listener of leadership
to think about hearing what he's saying
contemplating the frame of reference he
had and how it applies
to our world which is
you don't need to be in world war one to
recognize how
absolutely directly affected you can be
by thinking about what he's saying and
applying it to your day-to-day life
and how you interact with other people
which is kind of crazy to think about it
but it's also true and i guess
if there's a problem with any of this if
there's a problem with any of
the things that you're saying is that
there's nothing sexy about the indirect
approach
it doesn't like it doesn't play well
like you're not i'm gonna get to get up
and give a speech about the indirect
approach
men we're gonna subordinate our egos
today like
it doesn't the the language doesn't work
it doesn't
it doesn't give you that sad that
immediate satisfaction that people want
with
klossowitzy and total war
but th what's what's crazy is how
obvious is
how obvious it is to think about how it
helps you achieve the ultimate objective
which is winning the war
and how much more satisfying that is
than just winning a battle or
that then losing the war so for for
whatever it lacks in
in the excitement of the language of
we're gonna destroy every single aspect
of our enemy
down to the ground
this actually is the tool that you need
to be successful in anything
this is how you actually win that's how
you win
yeah it's very counter cultural it's
very
like you said it doesn't sell well it
doesn't sell well
i mean you can imagine stonewall jackson
standing up and saying all right guys
the enemy is a half mile down there we
are going to take the fight to them and
people getting fired up
as opposed to saying hey the enemy's
right down there
and we're going to walk 14 miles right
now
to go and hit him from where he doesn't
really expect it
because we don't want to have to face
his really we don't want to have to face
his strength we're a little scared to do
that
so we're going to walk around and kind
of sucker punch him
you guys with me right it's just like
yeah it's like
it's really as opposed to you know
forward into the breach right
no not really we're gonna sneak around
and sucker punch somebody
who's with me but
it's how you win so
let's jump back into it
further revision of theory and trying to
revise any theory and readjust it for
better balance
oh isn't that interesting we're talking
about balance because this everything is
a dichotomy
again i owe royalties to the to the
liddell heart
family it is a help to have a background
of study
in the subject as long as one is willing
to modify
one's conclusions not interesting
we have to actually be willing to to
modify our conclusions
change our mind
i was so far as i know the first student
of war after
1914 to 1918 to make a re-examination of
the prevailing doctrines derived from
clausewitz
about the objective in war after calling
it in question
in a number of articles in the military
journals i was
i dealt with it more fully in paris
or the future of war 1925. this little
book began with a criticism of the way
that the orthodox
aim quote the destruction of the enemy's
main forces on the battlefield
end quote had been pursued in world war
one pointing out its indecisive
and exhausting results
to your point earlier like hey we want
to go and confront the enemy head on
cool we did that for three years at four
years
and we had not only we had
indecisive and exhausting results we
were exhausted we didn't get anywhere
god what a what a freaking sin
what a sin to expend all those lives
and be exhausted from it and have no
real decisive victory
continuing it went on to argue that the
advantages
of the moral objective showing how
armored forces might deliver a decisive
blow against the achilles heel of the
enemy army
which is the communication and command
centers which form its nerve system
and two how air forces besides
cooperating in this strategic action
might also strike with the decisive
effect direct
at a nation's nerve system and that is
its static civil centers of
industry so he's the first guy that said
hey
what we did in world war one sucked and
we shouldn't do it again
how about we use freaking tanks and
aircraft
to pierce the enemy
and cut off their communication and ruin
their industries
continuing the general staff prescribed
the book for the study
of the officers of the first
experimental mechanized force
when this was formed two years later the
air staff less surprisingly
made still fuller use of it there was
then a lack of
textbooks on air strategy and it fitted
the development
the developing trend of their views on
the subject
the chief of staff the chief of the air
staff distributed copies
to his fellow chiefs of staffs
what i have said now is thus a revision
after prolonged reflection
of what i wrote a quarter century ago
and in a vowel
of error over part of the thesis it
shows
so he's taking ownership of something
that he screwed up it shows how in
correcting
the balance one is apt to tilt
too far the other way this is something
i call classic team guy over correction
i would make i'd go guys be coming
through my training they make a mistake
hey you're micromanaging also they let
people do whatever they want or the
opposite
correcting the balance one is apt to
tilt too far the other way
t e lawrence observed in a letter he
wrote me in 1928 this is lawrence of
arabia this is a guy that
fought the arab revolt in the sinai and
palestinian
campaign in world war one i mean this
guy is a legendary
and lawrence of arabia says quote
the logical system of klaus wits is too
complete
what an opening line the logical system
of clausewitz is too
complete it leads astray his disciples
those of them at least who would rather
fight with their
arms than with their legs
[Music]
what a freaking statement to open up a
letter
rather fight with their arms and with
their legs
what an epic statement actually it's
kind of a kind of uh
goes in with my
disciplinary freedom field manual
talking about you know oh
you wanna fight you wanna you wanna know
self-defense cool you wanna punch me i'm
gonna run away
you wanna kick me cool i'm gonna run
away i'm gonna fight with my legs
not with my arms
continuing on you at present are trying
with very little help from those
whose business it is to think upon their
profession to put the balance straight
after the orgy of the last war
when you succeed about 1945
these are like little jokes he's making
because he's writing this in 1928
when you succeed about 1945 your sheep
will pass your bounds of just discretion
and have to be shivved back to some
later strategist
back and forward we go
end quote in 1925 i myself
went too far in arguing the advantages
of the air stroke at civil objectives
though i did qualify this by emphasizing
the importance of executing it in such a
way
as to inflict the least possible
permanent injury for the enemy of today
as the customer of the morrow and the
ally
of the future
who would think that that's possible who
would think that germany would become
our ally
right who would think that the japanese
we would rebuild them to a point
of like of you know economic power
where we're in total cooperation with
totally
my belief then was that a decisive air
attack would inflict less total damage
and constitute less of a drain
on the defeated country's recuperative
power
than a prolonged war of the existing
type in further study i came to realize
that an air attack on industrial centers
was
unlikely to have an immediate decisive
effect and more likely to produce
another prolonged war
of attrition in fresh form with perhaps
less killing but more devastation
than from 1918 1914 to 1918
world war one but when one began to
point this out
one soon found that the air staff was
far less receptive to the revised
conclusion than to the original
conclusion
they continued to cherish faith in a
speedy decision and when war experienced
compelled them to relinquish it they
pinned their faith instead on
industrial attrition as fervently as the
general staff of the last word done to
manpower attrition
we're not learning lessons god
collective egos at play just not
learning lessons
a lot of this is why like i said i've
said a couple times now that this book
and the
these this strategy is a setup for me
for another series of podcasts that i
want to do and it's all going to come
so become so clear
nevertheless a realization of the
drawbacks and
evils of taking the civil fabric as the
objective does not mean the restoration
of
battle in the old sense of the objective
the drawbacks of that klaus
klaus whitsey and formula were amply
shown in world war one
in contrast world war ii demonstrated
the advantage of
new potentialities of indirect or
strategic
action against a military objective
amply confirming
what had been forecast in that respect
is he saying yeah i told you so yes he
is he's saying i told you so
i told you that these things i told you
that this air that this
mechanized fast-moving elements
could change the face of war especially
when coupled with air power
i told you so
even in the past such action had been
effectively exploited by some of the
great captains
despite the limitations of their
instruments but now with the help of new
instruments
the airplane the tank it proved still
more decisive
despite the increased strength of
tactical resistance
the new mobility produced a flexibility
in varying the direction of
thrust and threat which disarmed such
resistance
and and that's what we talked about
podcast
france poland the balkans just
disarmed resistance the time has come
for a fresh revision of the doctrine
of the objective or military aim in
light of recent experience and present
conditions
it is much to be desired that it should
be undertaken on combined service basis
to produce an agreed solution for there
is a dangerous
discordance of doctrines at presence
the outlines of a revised theory fitted
to present conditions and knowledge have
emerged i hope in
course of this discussion of the subject
the
key idea is strategic
operation rather than battle
an old term that has outlived its
suitability and utility
so get rid of this whole idea of battle
battles may still occur
but should not be regarded as the aim
itself
to repeat an earlier conclusion that was
strikingly vindicated in world war
ii quote the the true aim is not so much
to seek battle
as to seek a strategic situation so
advantageous
that does not of itself produce the
decision that if it does not of itself
produce the decision
its continuation by a battle is sure to
achieve this
that's what we're looking for and have
your opponent recognize that before the
battle takes place
optimally yes optimally they go you know
what we don't even have a chance
if they don't recognize it cool you're
in such a good position
that it doesn't matter anyways and the
battle's over very quickly yeah
i mean i'm writing things down i mean
just the things inside what he just said
how about just the first thing of
of the comment about study is designed
to modify conclusions
not not to validate your conclusions
like i'm going to go to research
and i'm going to literally just overlook
and bypass anything that doesn't
align with what i already think i know
i'm just like that's not convenient i'm
going to skip that so i'm going to find
i'm going to study so i can find
information to reinforce what i already
know
he's like no i'm doing the study to
figure out what i what i thought
that's actually wrong to modify my to
modify my conclusions
the the inherent humility
in that approach is i'm going to study
to find out where i'm wrong
how hard that actually is to do and then
he used the air staff as example and of
course you know the air staff is a thing
that didn't even exist
and now it's this thing where the
counter culture there they're the
opposing view of hey we need to look at
these things differently
and then how quickly how quickly
they solidified around their new
approach and became the inflexible rigid
we are going to stick to these
conclusions we're going to stay to these
we are not going to change
our our our viewpoint of this and how
quickly that that process happens to
human beings do not want change no they
really don't
and they really like to dig into
whatever they got to hold when they got
a hold of something they hang on to it
totally it's like trying to pry a toy
it's like a little freaking kid
a three-year-old with a rattle
you know what i'm saying they got that
rattle go and try and take that away
from them
why is that it's a human instinct to
hang on to what you got
and you see the general staff after 32
years of military service and 150 years
of combined military service between
these three
four generals and and and they have that
new rattle that they got a hold of
and they won't let go of it yeah
and they're gonna kick and scream it's
disturbing
it's crazy and he said something too
that that
he's referenced you've you've already
said it and
and this one kind of finally stuck is is
he's making the connection to leadership
he he's not talking about clausewitz so
much he keeps saying
about his students his disciples the
influence he had on a generation of
leaders
and the the the tragedy
that was created by that based on
klaus woods's influence over people and
he's made the illusion too like
that really wasn't his intent it wasn't
his intention he definitely last podcast
he definitely pointed out that it was
not his intent totally
but the power for better for worse the
power of that leadership
and if you have disciples and you've
said this over and over again
and again i i don't remember the exact
quote but the the the the uneducated
disciples
are more dangerous than the enemy
and to to just blindly follow
the language or the words of the leader
and just try to go implement
them without truly understanding the
context
and then the evolving application of
that to the world that they're going to
be in
it's i mean i put from from those two
pages just pulling out those three those
things and how critical those things are
can you fathom the freaking
group think that's going on check it out
not only
is everyone on my side bought into this
[ __ ] so my entire freaking
army of millions of people
is all bought into this idea and
your side and your millions of soldiers
and leaders
are all bought to the same idea imagine
how crazy that is
imagine how crazy it is that our group
think is so strong that
both opposing sides both are bought into
the same group think
at the peril of millions of soldiers
like that's nuts to think how strong
that group think is to think
i'm looking at you and you're doing the
exact same thing as me
and i'm thinking well we're just gonna
keep doing it and you're looking at me
thinking we're gonna keep doing it and
neither one of us is able to say you
know this doesn't make any sense
hey are you looking at what our enemy's
doing this this is
this seems kind of dumb the power of the
group thinks there
the power of you know we always talk
about
right you gotta detach and you gotta
take you know take a more strategic view
these are the freaking generals
on both sides at the same time at the
same time
wrapped up in the identical groupthink
when they are getting
a daily dose of reality
the the most stark reality that human
beings have
ever seen ever the most stark reality
that human beings have ever seen they're
getting slapped in the face with that
on the daily basis and they never look
around and say
hey you know what this is freaking
stupid what are we doing
this is the sickest group thing
fashionable it's crazy
so it's detached it's detached but like
detaching to the
strategic levels not enough
if you're surrounded if you're
completely surrounded if you're in uh
uh the virtual reality goggles on right
no matter where you look it's like
you're in the game
you need to take those things off your
head
right this is the last chapter that
we're going to cover in this book
it's called grand strategy
and it's going to tie into a lot of
things this book is concerned with
strategy rather than with grand strategy
or war policy to deal
adequately with this wider subject would
require
not only a much larger volume but a
separate volume
for while grand strategy should control
strategy its principles
often run counter to those which prevail
in the field
of strategy
for that very reason however it is
desirable to include here some
indication of the deeper conclusions to
which
a study of grand strategy lead leads
the object in war so this is an
interesting setup right
the setup is hey what i've been talking
about at this
strategic level we're actually gonna
we're actually gonna have some
principles that are counter to that when
we go up one more level so this is a
very interesting setup
the object in war is to attain a better
piece even
if only from your own point of view
hence it is essential to conduct war
with constant regard to the peace you
desire
that would appear to be common sense
what are we trying to get done how can
we get it done
not just to win right now but how can we
set ourselves up in the
grand future so that we're doing what we
wanted so we're in a situation we want
to be in
this is the underlying cloud switch's
definition of war as a
quote continuation of policy by other
means end quote the prolongation
of that policy through the war into the
subsequent priests
must always be born in mind so you can
you always have to think about the
future
you have to think strategically over
time at all times
a state which expands its strength to
the point of exhaustion bankrupts its
own policy and future
again what's the roi what's the roi and
what we're doing
we're expending all of our capital to
make something happen
and we look up and cool we made it
happen but we have no capital left we
can't pay our employees
we can't order any more of our supplies
good job no not a good job
if you concentrate exclusively on
victory with no
thought for the after effect you may be
too exhausted to profit
by the peace while it is almost certain
that the peace will be a bad one
containing the germs of another war
this is a a lesson supported
by abundant experience
i i brought up this quote again or one
of the previous podcasts about hey
cool you won and now you're in charge of
a wasteland
how about a leadership capital
perspective cool i got dave to do what i
told him to do
and now he hates working here and he's
not going to do a good job and he's
putting his
resume out there to everybody else good
job cool but i got him to do what i
wanted me to do
i won but he's got the germs of another
war
yeah and by the way go look at what
happened between world war one and world
war ii that's
exactly what it is that's what he's
referring to i mean
other examples but there's that's a
freaking perfect one
no one was happy at the end of that war
the risks become greater still in any
war that is waged by a coalition
for in such a case a a to complete
victory inevitably
complicates the problem of making a
justin wise peace settlement
where there is no longer a
counterbalance of an opposing force to
control the appetites of victors
there is no check on the conflicting
views and interest between part of the
alliance what a brilliant statement
right
this is 19 i guess he's one
yeah this is this is so this is after
world war ii yeah absolutely it has to
be
i mean that reference to america and
russia like that
yep cool yep we work together and as
soon as we don't have our common enemy
anymore
now we're pissed at each other
the divergences then apt to come so
acute as to turn
the comradeship of common danger into
the hostility of mutual dissatisfaction
so the ally of one war becomes the enemy
in the next there you go
hello soviet union yeah versus america
this raises a further and wider question
the friction that commonly develops in
any alliance system especially when it
has no balancing force
has been one of the factors that have
fostered numerous attempts throughout
history to find solution infusion
so joining together this is like in a
platoon
you have a platoon if you leave them
alone for a little while they'll start
fighting each other
that's just what's going to happen no
there's no balancing force there's no
one to go against
even if it's just the training cadre
that's enough of a you know we'll go
against those guys or another platoon
once they're alone they're going to
start fighting each other
so we look for we look for solutions in
fusion but history teaches us that in
practice this is apt to mean domination
by one of the constituent elements
and although there is a natural tendency
toward the fusion of small groups and
the larger ones
the usual result of forcing the pace is
the confusion of the plans to establish
a comprehensive political unit kind of i
will say that's a pretty pessimistic
view
it's a realistic view but it's a
pessimistic view
moreover regrettable as it may seem to
the idealist the experience of history
provides little warrant for the belief
that real progress
and the freedom that makes progress
possible lies in unification
and this is something we need to pay
attention to for where unification has
been able to establish unity of ideas
it has usually ended in uniformity
paralyzing the growth of new ideas
and where unification has merely brought
about an artificial or imposed unity
it is irksome irksomeness has led
through discord to disruption i love
that that from a leadership perspective
right
we get everyone on board with the plan
hey listen everyone just lock it up
we're going with my plan
seems to help right it seems to help but
by the way no one's now thinking
and on top of that people are pissed
discord
so now as soon as something goes wrong
you know we got an element that's
breaking off you got people complaining
why is that we're trying to
force uh uniformity
we're trying to force people to think
the same way it's a problem
vitality springs from diversity which
makes for real progress
so long as there is mutual toleration
based on the recognition that worse may
come from an attempt to suppress
differences
than from acceptance of them
again if you're a leader and you've got
someone that's a little outside the
lines and all you do is beat them into
submission
it's not helping
for this reason the kind of piece that
makes progress possible is best assured
by the
mutual checks created by a balance of
forces alike in the sphere of
internal politics and of international
relations
so
he goes into a little bit about the you
know the
the balance of power and politics right
he says he he says any monopoly of power
leads to
ever repeated demonstrations of the
historical truth epitomized in lord
acton's famous dictum all power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
another conclusion which develops from
the study of grand strategy against the
background of history is the practical
necessity of adapting the general theory
of strategy to the nature of a nation's
fundamental policy
you've got to make sure you're aligned
got to make sure you're aligned
it goes into some the difference between
an
an acquisite acquisitive state and a
conservative state meaning hey
my state is going out to acquire other
properties like we're going to go
go on the attack and a conservative
state which is hey we're just trying to
maintain what we've got
the acquisitive state inherently
unsatisfied needs to gain victory in
order to gain its object
and must therefore court greater risks
in the attempt
the conservative state can achieve its
object by merely
inducing the aggressor to drop his
attempt at conquest
by convincing him that the game is not
worth the camp
in victory its victory is in a real
sense attained by foiling
one's bid one side by foiling the other
side's bid for victory
indeed in attempting more it may defeat
its own purpose
by exhausting itself so much that it is
unable to resist other enemies
or the internal effects of over-strain
self-exhaustion in war has killed more
states than any
foreign assailant and how often do we
see that in companies
how often do we see in companies where
they are just
going so hard and investing in so many
different places
and chewing up their teams
we have to you have to be cognizant
of that
weighing these factors of the problem it
can be seen that the problem of a
conservative state
is to find the type of strategy that is
suited to fulfill its inherently more
limited
object in the most strength conserving
way
so as to ensure future as well as
presence now
there's a reason i'm i'm covering this
part because of this statement at first
glance it might seem
that pure defense would be the most
economical method
but this implies static defense and
historical experience
warns us that it is dangerously brittle
method on which to rely
economy of force and deterrent effect
are best combined in defensive offensive
method
based on high mobility that carries the
power
of a quick repost
and a quick repost a repost is a is a
move in fencing it's a thrust in fencing
so it's cool to think you know what
we're just going to conserve we're going
to stay here we're going to be on the
defensive
but we have to remember that
historically speaking
and when he's talking about historically
speaking he's talking about a massive
swath of history that he's looked at to
confirm
that you got to have some offense you
got to be on offense
and we say this a lot like if you're if
you're just if you're
not growing you're you're losing totally
he's also clearly
learned the lesson that he's kind of
accused klaus of not
applying which is the context to the
statements
where you say hey the conservative
approach
and oh by the way if you're over there
thinking that i'm telling you
dig in and be conservative that's not
what i'm saying
and to clarify and have the the
understanding of the comment itself
so the comment or the headline doesn't
become the story
which he he referenced so many times of
hey this statement became its own
the interpretation of the statement
became its own truth when it's not
really what he meant
but he didn't actually take the time to
make sure his disciples his learners
understood i'm not saying dig in
i'm not saying that and i know if you're
hearing that let me be let me be more
clear what this approach really means
and that's clearly a lesson he's taken
from the the other leaders that didn't
do that
and that the outcomes that that creates
when you don't actually explain what you
mean we talked about it almost
as a joke inside here of don't care or
you know hold the line
and if you're hearing i hold the line on
all things
let me be more clear that's not what i'm
saying i'm saying this this and this and
this is how you apply this
so i really like the idea that he's he's
taking the comment
and then giving the context around so
people can understand what he's talking
about
the people that are actually studying
what he's saying the
idea of the dichotomy of leadership that
idea
came to me because i was working with
these young
junior officers and you know what they
want to do they want to do good
totally they want to do good so if you
tell them
to be aggressive cool got it
they are on freaking level 14 berserker
mode
they're charging into whatever you tell
them
not to move um
you tell them hey make sure you take the
high ground
cool guess what they're doing they're
running to the top of every
freaking hill that they see yeah so so
anything that i would tell them there
was a there was they had a proclivity to
take it to the extreme and so within
like
one or two iterations at our land
warfare
training facility i was like okay i
gotta tell these guys that there has to
be balance that everything that i'm
saying has to be balanced
every single thing that i'm saying has
to be balanced if you take anything that
i'm saying and you take it to an extreme
it's gonna be bad
so i tried to do the same thing
it's kind of a universal man i hate to
say it's like a cop out
you know because it's like whoa you know
if your ego is you're saying ego is no
good no actually it's a balance
right and it kind of sounds like a
cop-out does it sound like a little bit
of a compound echo charles you seem to
agree with me
yeah i mean it can yeah
but no yes but no i mean it's a real
bummer i think some
not a bummer but someone will say well
you're saying that
uh you know you're saying that the ego
is bad but the egos
the egos what you know i don't want to
hire people the bunch of pushovers
yeah it's like yeah i know man that's
the dichotomy and they're kind of like
oh
like they think i don't have that they
forget that i have that you know
and that's why i feel like bad sometimes
pulling the dichotomy card
but it's the truth yeah the truth is man
you take something to the extreme and
it's bad yeah that's the truth
you still don't like it no i i agree
with you
where it's like you know that it's not a
cop-out in fact it's the opposite of a
cop-out
it's like you got to be real specific
and you got to use judgment you got to
you know
there's just more to it than that in
fact when someone doesn't recognize the
dichotomy that might be the more of the
cop-out it's kind of like oh you say go
here oh i went there i went there that's
what you said right and it's like right
you got to start using your judgment a
little bit you know
yep you were you were talking about
does it sound like a cop-out and in
in these scenarios of top gun you know
everything is like a scenario what do i
do in this situation and how do i react
to this
and like the classic answer the classic
answer was always
it depends which had this feeling of
like
yeah it's a cop-out it's a cop-out and
like oh you don't really know or you
don't have to be definitive because
there are times when people want want a
black and white they want a black and
white answer hey if i have this
situation what do i do it depends well
it actually depends
and but it actually does depend it it it
does not cop out it's not a cop-out
sounds like one though it does and
because it's not satisfying
and it requires like contemplation
and understanding of the nuance and how
did i get here in the first place what
am i trying to accomplish
so i was just thinking to myself when
you were talking about this
this uh this feeling of that sounds like
a cop-out was the
the answer i gave 5 000 times the top
gun to the students is that it depends
yeah
and then you got to dig in and go
through it and go well actually in in
the case that you're describing
this might actually be a better answer
than in the same situation but driven by
another
goal or got there for a different reason
hey i might go a different direction
here yeah
and then you as a leader have to
actually apply some judgment in real
time as opposed to
this situation requires this response
well it's that's not that simple
hey assault team leader what are you
doing way back there when there's when
they're all bogged down up in the front
yeah well you told me not to get engaged
in like the room to room clearance
totally yeah but they're bogged down
yeah
your example of where should the platoon
commander be in a patrol
it depends yeah where it makes sense
totally could be in the front could be
in the back
it could be in the middle you know and
and i i guess we've hit this i'm
probably beating a dead horse a little
bit but
but the unsatisfying nature of that
answer when i got to um
the basic school i'm i'm a brand new
second lieutenant
and uh we get to the the the basic
school and
right outside of the main headquarters
building is this
giant bronze statue of a lieutenant and
he's in this pose he's got his rifle
he's pointing his arm up and it says
follow me you know which is
what they push you is lead from the
front get out in front of your men
and and in a lot of ways that's right
that's right to to have that much but in
a lot of ways it's actually not
right but
place yourself where you need to be is
nowhere near
as cool as cool as follow
me lead from the front but if that's
what you hey i lead from the front like
cool you have no idea what's going on
back here and half your guys just got
hammered because of that
there's this i think this compulsion
which is why the klaus which thing plays
so well
to the the even just the catch phrases
of leadership
which don't actually serve a leader very
well lead from the front
who's going to say look that's a that's
a terrible leadership philosophy but
actually sometimes
you don't want to be in the front yeah
which is why i have a section in
leadership strategy and tactics which is
actually called lead from the rear
so it kind of like you have to like the
more under
because there has to be the formula
right at some level
like obviously at this at the surface
the formula is like
or you might someone might make the
mistake the formula is uh
lead from the front at all times right
but that's not the formula
formula is it depends okay on what then
there's a formula under there
but then under there you're like okay
well if this and this and this oh well
it depends a little bit more and the
deeper you go there has to be some
formula right
no okay so that and that's what i was
going to say too here
so the the solution no wait i have the
formula you know what the formula is
it's a dichotomy or dave will tell you
the formulas it depends
yeah so i feel like you're like yeah so
both those are cop-out answers you don't
want to hear them no no no
no i'm actually agreeing with you like
that that's what i would have said too
it all it's going to always depend
so and also on top of it there's more
than one right
answer a lot of the time or pretty much
all the time pretty much with very few
exceptions i would think
there are wrong answers oh yeah yeah i
agree with that too
okay but you're saying there's more than
one right answer right many cases
yes so i would say the solution is
the more you understand about all of it
the better decision you can make and the
better the better
educated you will be on what decision to
make given
the parameters of all the dichotomies
you're dealing with
except for the fact that you may not
have enough information to make the
decision that
seems like it's going to be the perfect
decision in which case you
kind of screwed up by not moving a
little bit more quickly and making
decisions based on the information that
you had at that current moment
yeah but when i meant when i meant
what i meant by knowing like educated
yourself not on
any specific scenario i'm saying on how
it works
on the dichotomy of leadership or on the
laws of combat or whatever
okay yes understanding well yeah then
you're going back to what i said which
is the formula is it's a dichotomy yeah
and you got to be balanced
yeah that's the formula the formulas be
balanced yeah
like some the more you know about the
whole game we'll say
the more you know when you're going to
be on this side of the dichotomy or i'm
leaning on this side of the dichotomy
the more you know about yourself the
more you know about your guys building
relationships by the way the more you
know about this and the more about how
this works then you're going to know
more about
under what types of circumstances you're
going to lean here early in there
you know what's cool we have a business
called echelon front
yes sir the reason we have a business
called echelon front is because
we have to help leaders work through
these issues
we can't give them a formula that they
can then apply across the board in all
situations
but like you're saying correctly if they
learn and understand the principles
they can start to make better decisions
and write decisions
based on their understanding of these
principles and applying them
holistically to their scenario right yes
exactly right
i was going to say yeah exactly what i'm
saying where
where do you get the formula from oh
you're probably the most educated on
this whole game
as far as the game goes right so the
more you let's say you consult with a
client
right the more you consult with them
hopefully the more they're gonna learn
that same
game and they're going to need you less
and less yes
that's the goal yes sir absolutely
all right back to the book the
east roman empire was a case
where such an actively conservative
strategy had been carefully thought out
as a basis of war policy
a fact which goes far to explain this
empire's unrivaled
span of existence another example more
instinctive than reasoned
is provided by the strategy based on sea
power
that england practiced in her wars from
the 16th to the 19th century
the value of it was shown by the way
that her strength kept pace with her
growth
while all her rivals broke down and
turned through self-exhaustion and war
traceable to their immoderate desire for
the immediate satisfaction of outright
victory
a long series of mutually exhausting and
devastating wars
above all the 30 years war has brought
had brought statesmen by the 18th
century to realize
the necessity when engaged in war of
curbing both their ambitions and their
passions
in the interests of their purpose
on the one hand this realization tended
to produce a tacit limitation of warfare
and avoidance of
excesses which might damage after the
war prospects so he's going back in time
and saying look we kind of learned these
lessons it was a regression that's why
earlier in the last podcast we talked
about he talked about klaus wits was a
regression
we were going backwards because they had
figured this stuff out the 30 years war
i mean
that's the 1600s you got germany and
sweden fighting spain and catholics
first probably
all kinds of crazy warfare going on to
no to no real decisive victory it's a
problem they realized that
their ambitions and passions frequently
carried them too far so that the return
to peace found their countries weakened
rather than strengthened but they'd
learn to stop
short of national exhaustion
which again you take that for leadership
capital
and we're expending more than we have
at the most satisfying at the at and the
most
satisfactory peace settlements even for
the stronger side proved to be those
which were made by negotiation rather
than
decisive military issue
this gradually education in inherent
limitations of war
was still in process when it was
interrupted by the french revolution
which brought to the top men who were
novices in statement statesmanship
the directory and its successor napoleon
pursued the vision of an enduring peace
through war after war for 20 years
there you go napoleon going for peace
20 years of war the pursuit never led to
the goal
but only to spreading exhaustion and
ultimate collapse
the bankruptcy of the napoleonic empire
renewed a lesson
that had often been taught before
the impression however came to be
obscured by the sunset haze of
napoleonic myth
the lesson had been forgotten by the
time it was repeated in the war of
in the world war one even after that
bitter experience
the statement of the second world war
were no wiser
although war is contrary to reason since
it is a mean of deciding issues by force
when discussion fails to produce an
agreed solution
the conduct of war must be controlled
by reason if its object is to be
fulfilled
and here he goes into how we reasonably
conduct war one
while fighting is a physical act its
direction
is a mental process the better your
strategy
the easier you will gain the upper hand
and the less it will cost you
very important thing to think about
two conversely the more strength you
waste
the more you increase the risk of the
scales of war turning against you
and even if you succeed in winning
victory the less strength you will have
to profit by peace
just just apply that one to world war
one and it's like okay we need to stop
this
three the more brutal your methods
the more bitter you will make your
opponents with the natural result
of hardening the resistance you are
trying to overcome
thus the more evenly the two sides are
matched the wiser it will be to avoid
extremes of violence which
tend to consolidate the enemies troops
and people behind their leaders
i mean okay war yeah what about
leadership perspective on that one
no like the more brutal the more you the
more you you shut up dave and do what i
told you to do
shut up team this is what we're doing
the more you do that
the more resistance you're gonna have to
overcome
four these calculations extend further
the more intent you appear to
impose a piece entirely of your own
choosing by conquest
the stiffer the obstacle you will raise
in your path
so when i make a piece that's completely
you know
in my favor cool i'm gonna end up with
problems
and the more i impose a plan on dave and
his team
the more i'm gonna end up with problems
and i can see the looks on the people's
faces
in a company when i tell them that
it's so hard to believe it's so hard to
believe that hey
actually the more efficient way is to
say hey dave how do you want to do this
it's so hard to believe that
it seems so much more efficient for me
to say hey dave here's the plan shut up
and do it
here give this to your team here's the
orders go execute
which is funny because people go oh you
know these military these military wave
leading wouldn't work in the civilian
world it's like what are you talking
about
it's always fun life's like yeah yeah
this is what exactly what jocko did with
me he'd be like hey how do you want to
do it i'd be like oh this sounds like a
good plan okay
okay cool
five furthermore if and when you reach
your military goal
the more you ask of the defeated side
the more trouble you will have
and the more cause you will have to
provide for an ultimate attempt to
reverse the settlement achieved by war
again when you impose your plan on
people when you impose your will on
people
there will be organ rejection of that
force is a vicious cycle or rather
a spiral unless its application is
controlled
by the most carefully seasoned
calculation
just just think about that there's a
common thing i tell clients
minimum you want to lead with minimum
force required that's how you want to
lead
if i don't have to say anything that's
the best if i have to say hey this is
maybe an idea
if i get to a point where i have to bark
an order at someone and tell them shut
up and do what i told you to do that's
bad that's
that's the vicious circle of force we
don't like it
thus war which begins by denying reason
comes to vindicate it vindicate it
throughout all phases of
the struggle the fighting instinct is
necessary to success
in the battlefield so the fighting
instinct we gotta be ready to fight the
fighting instinct is necessary to
success in the battlefield
although even here the combatant who can
keep a
cool head has an advantage over the man
who sees red
so that's his little caveat and then he
says but
the fighting instinct should always be
ridden on a tight reign
the statesman who gives that instinct
its head
loses his own if you just want to scrap
cool guess what's going to happen you're
going to lose your own head
he's not fit to take charge of the fate
of a nation
victory in the true sense implies that
the state of peace
and of one's people is better after the
war than before
victory in this sense is only possible
if a quick result can be gained or if a
long effort can be economically
proportioned
to the national resources how much are
you investing
how much are you investing of capital
from your company how much are you
investing in leadership capital
roi where's it at the end must be
adjusted to the means
we throw that one out all the time and
it's
and it's got like the connotations of
being a wimp focus on your goal
there's 48 freaking uh uh
uh inspirational memes
a day set your goal
and never fear from it cool i got a
better idea how about the end must be
adjusted to the means
right it's that's not very interesting i
want that lambo
i want a dream board i got a lambo and i
got an infinity pool
cool how's that wendy's
salary kicking in right
adjust your means a little bit man
adjust the end to
fit the means sure oh this is this is
again no one's there's no there's no
there's not one single
inspirational meme on the gram that says
that says the end must be adjusted to
the means no one says that actually it's
the opposite
as far as in the inspirational uh quotes
industry well for lack of a better
chance it's the exact opposite actually
oh yeah yeah
it's like hey basically it's like okay
adjust the men's to the means right
or the into the means right so it's kind
of like hey don't freaking have this
goal that's like unrealistic essentially
essentially yeah fact like it's
unrealistic right
like it it's a responsibility to respond
you have an irresponsible goal right
there
you can like whatever kill yourself
doing it right you should go in the
comments should be like
you're dumb it shouldn't be right given
that
right but if you say it but they'll talk
about there's someone right now that's
going to hear this music
oh yeah if you're down for the thing and
i get it because double tap
uh heart like if you want to be a
you know for your first hundred million
oh yeah foot yeah
oh there's people that tap that twice oh
yeah right 100 yes sir
and and like for a moment they're kind
of like pumped
yeah i'm sure they're pumped the whole
time
until the ends really but the no well if
you're the guy if you're the guy who
says this what this book is saying hey
like the end must be adjusted to the
means that's a good goal like that's a
lofty goal
which you know obviously you can't hate
on lofty goals
wait that's not even really a lofty goal
that's just a realistic thing to do as a
human but the realistic they're making
realistic human memes
yeah well in a way you know the first
one would be the end must be adjusted to
the media it's very not inspirational
they would get down voted yeah you'll be
branded as the hater really
like that's what that's the point where
they they'll brand you as a hater like
everyone's always hating and
this goes into uh the whole idea dave
that you were talking about of like
about hey this isn't really sexy this is
the absolute like
non this is getting down voted this is
getting haters
and and what's interesting is who are
you gonna who's gonna get the
up vote right yeah this person is
getting
you're getting hated oh yeah because
you're like actually it's an unrealistic
goal you should check yourself
right oh the downer the doubter right oh
yeah
yeah and the thing is i get it because
every once in a great while you'll get
someone who
achieved this super lofty goal not to
say that they didn't adjust the ends to
the means because they had the means
apparently
at the end of the day the means were
there because the end is there too right
but here's the thing they had that uh un
inspirational memes we'll just say
realistic realistic memes
yeah yeah but nonetheless they they
achieved that goal that was kind of
untip not typically
realistic it was unrealistic right
comparatively speaking or whatever and
they achieved it
i mean we could easily argue that
like oh this person did this because
they had the meme
the means yeah right well that's the
intellectual horsepower they had the
educational thing they had they had all
these things set up so it's actually a
realistic goal i know that that's what
i'm saying where
but they'll take the the the the crazy
quote-unquote unrealistic
uh ends right the goal we'll say
president but that's the one right the
classic
president of the united states you can
do anything you want oh i'm going to set
my goal the highest i possibly can in
life president united states
right so they'll be like all right cool
therefore we should all essentially set
goals as high as president united states
right okay that's kind of the
inspirational message
right okay meanwhile the very few
individuals that became president of the
united states had the means
so their ends technically by definition
were adjusted their ends were adjusted
to the means because they had the means
you see i'm saying
not everyone has them yes so you gotta
adjust those yeah
meanwhile everyone's saying no no no no
no don't if he can do it
i can do it too right which hey i'm not
saying
they can't i'm not even saying that but
i'm saying hey man
you got to be really realistic on that
kind of stuff yeah
see i'm saying but then if you say that
you just can't say that out you know
what's really crazy is
like i just got slapped in my own face
thinking about this because we're kind
of
joking about this but what he's saying
and what he saw
was hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of soldiers
that were killed because the leadership
didn't adjust the ends to the means
totally
which is crazy to think about and as you
guys were talking i was thinking in my
mind like
people have figured this out there there
are
even phrases out there the one i kept
thinking of as you're talking about this
is
i remember the phrase live within your
means
like i've heard that's a phrase what
it's not is
it's not hanging on a poster in any
kid's bedroom anywhere
yeah like i don't go to bed at night
like it's a nine-year-old going
i'm gonna live within my means the irony
inside that is the best way to
actually ultimately expand your means
over time so your means get greater and
greater is to do exactly that
like that's the trick to it is is the
the dissatisfaction of the reality is
something people
overlook and the the the unfunny part of
that
which is the sobering piece that you
just mentioned is that it can
actually lead people down a path
to do exactly what you just said which
which almost seems not possible
except for the fact that these that he
specifically lived that in a way that
goes
what are we doing here what are we doing
what are we expending
to a con and what are we accomplishing
by doing that so it wasn't just the
national exhaustion
it was the national exhaustion with
nothing to show for it
and then the scale of that which is
which is impossible
as opposed to hey why don't we operate
within our means here
why don't we do that yeah and if you
fast forward the kid if there was a kid
that had a poster on their wall that
said live within your means
and therefore they're saving and they're
putting together and you look at them in
20 years
and they're in a way better position
than someone that was like
you know you need the lambo
or whatever right because they're going
to end up in debt
and they can't invest properly and they
have to
work a job that they don't really like
and it's a job that's a dead end
like all these things add up you said
something about
you being an nba basketball player right
i would say
on record on a inspirational or
demotivational posts saying hey bro
that's unrealistic i would tell you that
yeah yeah
and i think factually it is unreal well
as far as factually goes
it is unrealistic i don't know that i
would tell a high school kid that
when he's really into basketball i don't
know if i would
i would say that like it'd be
unrealistic in certain ways like if
under certain circumstance or whatever
but given like how you consider it most
people how they get into like
professional sports whenever they work
hard they really love the sport
you know they go through trials and
tribulations or whatever and they end up
making it kind of a thing
so if you get someone that that's kind
of in the beginning of that
type of path right where that path is
not straight up blocked off for whatever
reason like it would be in your case
i wouldn't really say that's unrealistic
the point is there are really cases
where it's
unrealistic so if you try to
be an nba player hire the best coach in
the world
i i get it you would wind up
exhausting all your resources i should
adjust my my end times
yes sir you might want to make sure that
your kid who you don't want to stifle
that dream you might want to make sure
that they're not putting
all their eggs in that one basket and
two like hey listen
go for it but you're not gonna drop out
of school
you're not gonna stop doing this and
this
with the the ultimate meme of
focus on your goals and block out every
distraction so i i'm done with school
because school is stupid because school
ain't going to help me be
an nba player meanwhile you're five six
you're done growing
you're not that good of a shot but
you've got this this passion
you might want to keep that kid on the
track of hey cool i'm not here to crush
your dreams
however comma let's consider some other
things as you're doing that
actually you should never have a plan b
that means you're not fully committed to
your planning that's right
you got a plan b i guess you're not
committed to planning you're
inspirational
actually he addresses some of this here
uh going back to the book failing a fair
prospect of such a victory so the end
must be adjusted to the means failing a
fair prospect of such a victory
why statesmanship will miss no
opportunity for negotiating peace
peace through stalemate based on a
coincidence
recognition by each side of the
opponent's strength is at least
preferable to peace through common
exhaustion
and has often provided a better
foundation for lasting peace
it is wiser to run risks of war
for the sake of preserving peace than to
risk
run the risk of exhaustion in war
for the sake of finishing with victory
a conclusion that runs counter to custom
but is supported
by experience
so it's it's better to like maybe we
don't have war
and we just kind of maintain peace with
kind of what i've got
that's a better deal than you know what
we're just gonna we're gonna
exhaust ourselves and hope for some kind
of a victory
yeah perseverance in war
is only justifiable if there is a good
chance of a good end the prospect of a
peace that will balance the sum of human
misery incurred in the struggle
like each one of these statements dave
you just shake your head knowing where
it came from
that's all i'm thinking is every one of
these is is
what he what this comes from and just
how savage that experience had to have
been for him
indeed deepening the study of past
experience leads to the conclusion that
nations might often have come
nearer to their object by taking
advantage of a lull in the struggle to
discuss a settlement than by pursuing
the war
with the aim of victory history
so look man you got to look for those
opportunities we got a little lull
hey are you gonna keep going with this
or you want to maybe stand down
history reveals also that in many cases
a beneficial piece could have been
obtained if the statesmen
of the warring nations had shown more
understanding of the elements of
psychology in their piece
feelers so you get the peace feelers out
there like
what let me sense about what's happening
here
and people don't have good understanding
of their pee they don't recognize their
peace
feelers their attitude has commonly be
been too akin to to that seen in the
typical
domestic coral right so now we gotta
fight with our wife each party is afraid
to appear yielding
with the result that when one of them
shows any inclination towards co
conciliation this is usually expressed
in language that is too stiff
while the other is apt to be slow to
respond partly from pride
or obstinacy and partly from a tendency
to interpret such a gesture as a sign of
weakness
when it may be a sign of returning to
common sense classic
right i'm not going to apologize just
say you're sorry
yeah just say you're sorry don't look
weak
thus the fateful moment of passes and
the conflict continues
to the common damage right we are
killing ourselves over something that we
could easily say hey look i'm sorry it's
my fault
rarely does a continuation serve any
good purpose where
the two parties are bound to go on
living under the same roof
this applies even more to modern war
than to domestic conflict
since the industrialization of nations
has made their fortunes
inseparable it is the responsibility of
statesmanship
never to lose sight of the post-war
prospect
in chasing the mirage of victory
where to where the two sides are too
evenly matched to offer a reasonable
chance of early success to either the
statesman
is wise who can learn something from the
psychology
of strategy it is the elementary
principle of strategy that if you find
your opponent in a strong position
costly to force you should leave him a
line of retreat as the quickest way of
loosening his resistance
get personal way out it should equally
be the principle policy especially in
war to provide your opponent with a
ladder by which he can climb down
give people a way out
give your wife a way out in that
argument
give your subordinate a way out in that
argument give your boss a way out
don't make them dig in don't make them
fight to the death
the question may arise as to whether
such conclusions based on the history of
war
between so-called civilized states
applied to the conditions inherent
in a renewal of the type of purely
predatory war
that was waged by the barbarian
assailants of the
roman empire or the mixed religious
and predatory war that was pursued by
the fanatical followers
of muhammad in such wars
any negotiated peace tends to have
in itself even less than the normal
value
it is only too clear from the history
that states rarely keep the faith with
each other
save in so far and so long as their
promises seem
to them to combine with their interests
that's a good thing to note
right i'm not going to keep any promises
if they're not
for my benefit that's what history tells
us yeah
and now we're so now we're talking about
extremists
whether it's the barbarians attacking
the romans
or the islamists
attacking the west
back in the day but the less that a
nation
has regard for moral obligations the
more it tends to respect
physical strength the deterrent power of
a force too strong to be challenged with
impunity
so you got somebody that's not gonna you
know you make peace with them but you
don't trust them guess what you better
be strong
people that don't people that don't
respect the moral obligation they
respect
strength
in the same way with individuals it is a
matter of common experience that the
bully type and the robber type hesitate
to assail anyone who approaches their
own strength
check you don't see the bully picking on
the big yoked up guy with cauliflower
ears
it is folly to imagine that the
aggressive types whether individuals or
nations can be bought off
or in modern language appeased since the
payment
of dangeled simulates stimulates a
demand
for more dang geld what's dangel do you
ask
it's viking protection money like hey
you can live here i need some danger you
got to pay me a little bit of you know a
little bit of something something
okay and what does that do makes me want
more
oh the viking yeah the dang i asked you
like
i need some protection money from you
you know you can you can work this
corner but you know
you got to give me my cut what does that
make me want
more cut yeah yeah so you can't buy them
off
but they can be curbed their very belief
in force makes them more susceptible
to the deterrent effect of a formidable
opposing force this forms an adequate
check except against pure fanaticism a
fanaticism
that is unmixed
so you get pure fanaticism it doesn't
matter if i'm gonna kill you or not
you're gonna come
while it is hard to make real peace
with the predatory types it is easier to
induce them to accept the state of truth
and far
less exhausting than an attempt to crush
them whereby
they are like all types of mankind
infused with the courage of desperation
so we have to be strong
you have to be strong and
look if you're stronger than these
predatory fanatics
it doesn't necessarily mean you want to
go to war with them because they're
going to
fight desperately but if you're strong
and you can keep them in check
that's sort of a good balance of power
that's acceptable yeah
i'm i don't know how many more you've
got on this but i'm just
i'm thinking of all the things he's
describing all the
behavior and the reaction the action and
the reaction
it's all human nature it's all this is
how
a this is how they will respond to this
and
the repetitiveness and he keeps coming
back to this idea like hey this is not a
this is not a sample size of one
this isn't just one thing that's
happened in history and i think that's
the power of the idea of human nature is
this is how people will react
this is how people will respond and if
you understand human nature
i mean that to us is is is
the foundation of leadership this is a
human nature endeavor understanding how
people will react
and anytime we behave in the extremes
there will be a reaction to that
to to us operating in the extremes there
will be a natural human reaction
to some other extreme and he's like hey
do you want to subdue human nature be
moderate
limit the natural reaction hey have a
little bit of something over here have a
little something here but just
listening to all those things you're
saying is a human nature human nature
human nature human nature
yep and the response be balanced be
balanced balanced
be in the middle to limit to to minimize
the reaction that you're
going to get
total war cool you win guess what you
got now you got an insurgency
it's going to last for 20 years and is
that really what you want
or could you maybe operate with some
restraint understanding that what you're
really trying to do is not beat them
what you're really trying to do is
create a piece
for a couple of decades maybe could you
could you think of the long game here
again that's probably not going on a
poster somewhere
you don't you're not getting recruited
into the marine corps with that one yeah
here's a little um
maybe a little warning for us the
experience of history brings ample
evidence that the downfall of civilized
states
tends to come not from the direct
assaults of foes
but from internal decay combined with
the consequences
of exhaustion in war
yeah that's a little warning
a state of suspense is
trying
and and his usage of the word suspense
there is like
mental indecision a state of suspense
or mental indecision is trying it has
often led nations as well as individuals
to commit suicide because they were
unable to bear it
but suspense is better than to reach
exhaustion
in pursuit of the mirage of victory
that's a bold statement so
indecision can be so bad this this
existence of indecision can be so bad
that
you you can destroy yourself you can
kill yourself
you want to kill yourself
but that's actually better than to
just exhaust yourself completely in
pursuit of a
of a victory that can't be had
what's you know what's counterintuitive
about that is
you know this idea that humans
we need a goal we need something to go
towards right we need a goal we need
some we
want something we want to struggle we
want to fight
what he's saying here is like well let's
think twice about that one
let's think twice about that one
and i think it's probably because he
understands what the true
exhaustion of a state looks like
uh on a scale that most people can't
comprehend
yeah yeah and he's said this before i
finally read it the mirage of victory
the mirage what you are seeing this goal
that you're working towards
it's actually not a thing it's not a
real thing it's a mirage and you've
convinced yourself
victory for me is i defeat jocko that's
victory and i am going to move towards
that until it happens
but that's actually not a real thing
it's not a real thing
yeah it's not a real thing and what
you'll end up with is an insurgency
or exhaustion or exhaustion or whatever
else
or you or you'll rule over the barren
wasteland that i left
right moreover a
truce to actual hostilities enables a
recovery and development of strength
while the need for vigilance keeps a
nation on its toes
so we're looking for a truce it's okay
peaceful nations are apt however to
court unnecessary danger
because when once aroused they are more
inclined to proceed to extremes
than predatory nations
interesting right this is like the guy
that's sort of quiet
keeping to himself but when you piss
them off
you know then they freaking go ham
that's a technical definition as well
for the latter making war as a means of
gain
are usually more ready to call it off
when they find an opponent too strong or
too
easily overcome and this is really the
last point
for this book that we're going to talk
about
it is the reluctant fighter impelled by
emotion
and not by calculation who tends to
press a fight
to the bitter end thereby
he too often defeats his own end even if
he does not produce his
own direct defeat for the spirit of
barbarism can be weakened only during a
cessation of hostilities
war strengthens it pouring
fuel on the flames
so by attacking people by attacking
this the bar the barbarians when we
attack them
we make them stronger we make them
fight harder
war makes them s stronger makes them
fight makes them resist
pours fuel in the flames
we can only weaken them by by backing
off a little bit
again this is not the recruiting poster
it's and it's so
counter-intuitive it's so
counterintuitive to the natural reaction
of
push harder be more dominant
to get to get the outcome that you want
uh so look we're we're here for the
truce
we're we're here for the compromise like
it's just it's
so counterintuitive to what we what we
preach what we want
which is total victory i like total
victory that sounds good
it's a mirage yeah just never compromise
you know no compromise that's a that's
another
great you know inspirational me
because there's none that say hey it's
really good to compromise oftentimes and
kind of take what you can get and work
out a good deal and you know that's fair
[Laughter]
we're gonna get hammered for this oh
yeah some inspirational meme people are
gonna be mad at us
yeah and what's crazy is i mean you
could probably
you know open up uh dyspnea's freedom
field manual
we'll pull out some stuff like this i
got all kinds of stuff in there
getting crazy right
sure are you gonna make me crack it open
and start reading stuff no i'm not
guilty as charged i'm kind of wanting to
well the good thing about your book is
that it's not
it's not like you've done a good job
whether it be
in the book itself or compromise
page 32 discipline equals freedom field
manual when working with other people in
dynamic oh this is see this is kind of
cool
here's what it says this is just the
first thing i opened up to when working
with other people and dynamic situations
and relationships and deals a person
especially a leader must
compromise finding the common ground
between
teams merging different approaches to
the same problem
bridging personalities with people who
might not get along
reaching agreements in courses of action
all of these require compromise
and in many cases a failure to
compromise
is a failure to succeed i guess maybe
i'm wrong
i mean maybe i'm wrong about me writing
stuff that's inspirational meme
crap but those are external compromises
with
other people other humans that have
their own personalities and ethos and
issues
and compromises needed to unify so work
with them
compromise so to work with them
compromise is a must
not with yourself and then i wait but
internally it's different
with myself i have to hold the line
there are areas within myself where i
cannot compromise
i'm going to work hard i'm going to
train hard i'm going to improve myself
i'm not going to rest on my laurels
i'm going to confront my own mistakes
i'm going to own my mistakes and
confront them
i'm going to face my demons i'm not
going to give up or give out or give in
i'm going to stand i'm going to maintain
my self-discipline
and on those points there will be no
compromise not now
not ever whoa it's pretty inspiring
pretty uh we might go meme on that one
sure
yeah if you go from the headline to the
conclusion there and skip the content in
the middle where it says compromise
not now not ever you got a little claus
would see an issue here where your
disciples like
i didn't quite read the context but i
saw the page that said compromise you
know how it ended it said
not now not ever yeah it's not good
i think if we go through this book
here's one called fight
go down swinging and i'll tell you if
you fight with all you have more often
than not
you won't go down at all you will win
but you have to make that attitude part
of your everyday life do the extra
repetition run the extra mile go the
extra round
make the right choices give the full
measure
i'm in the game i think i'm in the
inspirational meme game
yeah you are but was gonna say it's like
yeah yeah
you do that but the good thing about
having a whole
book and a whole podcast and eight
million other books is
or whatever you're going to explain the
whole situation
rather than just have the one post you
see what i'm saying yeah i mean look
the the entire book is predicated i
think the opening salvo you have is
this is about you and you say i am
nothing but weakness i am nothing but
but false i am nothing but these things
so this is this is the
this is what you are with yourself with
self-discipline
as opposed to how i'm going to treat
other people
around me yes this is aimed internally
totally i mean in a literal sense and
that fight is against
i mean it's even in the video that we
show it at the most i am nothing but
weakness
and i'm gonna fight against that
weakness that compromise all those
things that
my mind is telling me to do to myself
which is
i think also you could look in the terms
like the difference between between
imposed discipline and self-discipline
imposed discipline does not work and
self-discipline does
it's as simple as that and as we impose
ourselves on other people in war
in leadership in parenting in insert any
human interaction
human and another human when you impose
your discipline when you impose yourself
on them
in the end you will lose but it's much
more efficient just to impose your way
yeah it's faster oh man
uh so there we go that's what we're
going to cover for this book
uh i've kind of i guess foreshadowed
some of the other things we'll do in the
future
and it's one of those things if you can
make
if you can take these lessons these
lessons written in blood
not just in one war but in war after war
after war
and the exclamation point of world war
one
you can learn a lot and you can apply
this and we know that it's not
as striking we know it's not as sexy
we know it's not as meme worthy
as some of the
more direct approaches
we know that but this is
to give the original name this is how
to win wars
with that speaking of winning wars echo
charles yes
we want to you know win the war
on ourselves we do
yeah that you when you say win
wars right win wars you don't ten this
is what the
one of the takeaways that i think hey
dang that's something good to remember
where when you think about warfare and
winning the war you don't think about
the peace that
afterwards you know like the aftermath
so i grew up on kauai
you know you know that so the thing
about kauai is like
if you get in a fight with someone and
you don't resolve it in a peaceful way i
don't care how
i don't care if it's the kind hey we
don't like each other for no good reason
and we
just fight him like okay we're cool we
fought and we're done if you don't
resolve it in some peaceful way you got
to deal with somebody's cousin
somebody's brother somebody's you know
whoever neighbor
who's just down for the cause or
whatever and you're gonna see him again
too that's the thing
you go to the store he's gonna be there
like next week or whatever you know
so it's kind of one of those things
where it's kind of in the back your mind
if i'm going to fight this guy i sort of
got to deal with that contend with that
long
that long game is there a methodology to
get that resolved
post fight yeah i think so i mean
i all the fights i've ever been in have
never
been like lasting like it'd be like a
fight and then we're friends afterwards
but i was a kid so i have very little
and i had very little understanding of
that
but nonetheless the point is where
that's something when we think of
warfare we think of oh defeat cross your
enemies haven't driven before you
you see him saying and we don't think
about that oh wait and you know you got
your neighbor his
freaking dog or whatever he's barking
his tree is growing over your fence and
you're getting you guys are warring
years it's like bro you don't have to do
that you know you got to live next to
that guy yeah
when you go to the post office or
whatever you go to your car and you see
him getting in his car too you're like
oh it's all awkward or whatever like bro
you don't have to do it like that you
know
are you really going to achieve the
peace that you hoped for by
beating this dude's ass right now yeah
or
chances are you're not real if you think
a little bit chances are you're not
thinking hey i'm going to go the
distance right now
like i'm ready to just go i'm ready to
go all in i'll fight every
cousin nephew brother sister no i don't
care
like but that's where you can end up
yeah we don't want we don't want to know
in fact that's a common thing especially
like with the neighbors or whatever
i'm going to tell them all it's usually
that kind where i'm going to tell them
off
i'm not going to take that from him or
her whatever and
meanwhile 10 20 30 years you're wearing
with this neighbor
right next door by the way the feud
that's
yeah it's total total common thing you
know when all you got to do is be like
hey
like you know make a peaceful
discourse and you guys can live uh
neighborly you see insane preferable but
anyway yeah so the point is like
thinking about that aftermath
or considering that it's a thing you
know i'm gonna do that
like if you roll with someone in
jiu-jitsu and you fight dirty because
you want to win
you know do that stuff then when you're
done rolling you tap them out hell yeah
everyone's talking about you oh yeah you
dirty nobody respects you nobody likes
you in the community
it's true you got to be careful with
that kind of stuff
all right so how can we you know win
the war that we're all fighting kind of
on an individual basis day to day with
um unmitigated daily discipline and
often i like it i like it
so when i say daily discipline i mean
the energy drink boom
so it's healthy for you and it gives you
the payoff that you'd expect from an
energy drink
so i'm saying so this is good news for
us anyway so on this path that we're all
on
we need some supplementation we could
benefit from supplementation
right so we got choco fuel to the rescue
in a sense
got energy drinks for you healthy good
short term and long term
we got protein additional protein tastes
real good we got dessert basically
dessert that's good for you yeah good
short term good long term
the aftermath of the mark of the protein
the dessert
it's a good aftermath that's a piece uh
peaceful truth same thing happy very
peaceful truth
yes sir also when your joints act up
when your immunity acts up we got some
stuff for that how about you don't let
your joints act up
how do we get into a continual state of
peace with our joints yeah yeah yeah
like
the situation because to wait waiting
for your joints to act up as a bad call
and i was about to say preemptive strike
on your joints yeah i mean you're like
hey i've got a cooperative
you know you're going down like the oh
yeah the right path here i'm like
preemptive strike
yeah yeah you're you're more tuned with
that hang on
marine corps recording per poster it is
called joint warfare
i mean it's called drain warfare
[Music]
until you have joint issues that's a
dumb call
that's what echo charles just told you
to do i'm i'm here to help
you know all right i'm just saying hey
if you don't want to worry about joint
issues you take the joint warfare and
the super acryl oil
yes that's it if you don't want to worry
about colds
or sicknesses or flus or whatever
you take the vitamin d3 you take the
cold water that's going to help you yeah
don't worry about stretching go to war
go to war
total or yeah fully um so you can get
all the stuff at vitamin shop
you can get all those uh the energy
drinks at wawa
and you can get all of everything on
jacofuel.com
and if look if you want to save a little
bit of money
and you want to save brain power you get
a subscription
get a subscription to whatever you want
it'll show up at your house once a month
boom there's the mulk there's the joint
warfare there's the super krill
it's coming in coming out you don't
worry worry about it you can focus on
something else you can prioritize and
execute some other
tasks yep speaking of brain power origin
usa
they got some american-made stuff how
does that have to do with brain power
right you know what i'm talking about
don't act like you don't know american
american-made denim
as far as jeans go i was going to call
you on a couple of those last podcasts
where
you know speaking of whatever i'm going
to talk about something totally
different that's sort of like become
your new mode no
yeah because you got to make the
association same thing speaking of
pickles
that's the brain origin you can get some
jeans
american-made denim that's a big deal
as far as american-made stuff goes you
got the denim you got your jeans
you got your geese rash guards you got
athletic wear you got belts you got
boots
all made in america origin usa boom
see see what i'm saying about the brain
power yeah that was definitely had a lot
to do with brain power
also uh speaking of a lot to do brave
how are you expended making that
connection
is pretty ridiculous speaking of
ridiculous chocolate has a store it's
half a watch
it's called jocko store
if you want your discipline equals
freedom shirts
right merch as far as merch goes you
know sure that says good on it
boom you can get it there you can get
all kinds of stuff uh hats
shirts guards
do you still sell the shirt with your
head on it dang you designed that shirt
you still sell that shirt with your head
on it yeah we still sell it
cool best seller really yes
uh it sells double the amount of the one
with your head on it
if you must know yeah nonetheless yes
this should the shirt that you could
design with my head is
on it on there dang a bunch of other
stuff on there as well we have a
subscription situation for the shirt
some other shirts they're exclusive
i said it exclusive okay it's called the
shirt locker if you're part of the short
locker you have
you get one of these shirts every month
it's a new their new kind of
creative for like a better term designs
if you're not part of the shirt locker
you don't get them sorry it's like the
nature of the
locker okay you went a little more
simple this time which was good i
appreciated the simplicity of it you
still can't describe what the shirts are
with any with any sensible
yeah well some things can't be explained
you know that's even better i like that
yeah
you even say look i can't really explain
this but trust me you know you're going
to want one of these shirts okay these
shirts cannot be explained jocko
they can only be experienced damn so you
make this choice whether or not you
experience it
by you wearing them or by you seeing
someone else wear them that's up to you
that part is up to you i think it's
really
you either regret what you have done or
what you have not done yeah
it's gonna be a lot a lot more regret on
what you have not done i think so too
you see somebody representing in a shirt
we're like oh that's cool i'm gonna pick
one of those up but you can't it's true
yeah that's what the field is telling me
as far as feedback goes so yeah i did i
agree with the field you know check this
out
anyway like i said jocko store.com
that's where you can get this cool stuff
speaking of cool stuff
yeah you can subscribe to this podcast
if you want to because echo seems to
think that you haven't
subscribed to it yet because you've been
listening to 285 episodes 287 episodes
that's where you're at you're like you
know what maybe today's the night
maybe i would get down hold on let me
whip out my iphone and just hit
subscribe smash the subscribe button
button the way it's going but yeah
so anyways we got this podcast we got
the jocko unraveling podcast
with dc daryl cooper
of martyr made fame we got the grounded
podcast
we got the warrior kid podcast we also
have jocko underground
where we have a a sovereign
location a virtual sovereign location
where we will not be impeded upon
by forces we will we will do what we
want
in the jocko underground look hey here's
what's going on in the world
there's things happening on these
platforms there's things happening these
platforms we don't control the platforms
we don't control the platforms there's a
possibility that things could happen
that could hurt what we're trying to do
whether they start charging you money to
listen on these platforms
whether they start inserting
advertisements into the middle of us
talking about world war
one or or vietnam and all of a sudden
you're listening to an advertisement
about
um uh whatever mattresses
right so we don't want to have that
happen
we definitely don't want to be censored
for whatever reason so we got to have an
alternative platform we made our own
jockowunderground.com look we hopefully
we never have to go to it
it's possible but if we do
we'll be ready and we appreciate the
support to get us ready
if you want to subscribe to that we do a
little extra pondcast
and we answer a bunch of questions we
give some amplifying information
if you want to join it cost eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month
and if you can't afford that it's cool
email assistance
jockowunderground.com we're just trying
to we
we're here to hook you up if you need it
but we appreciate you hooking us up as
well
freedom isn't free by the way yep
we got to maintain that freedom we got a
youtube
uh channel speaking of smashing the
subscribe button
and speaking of post like and comment
what is it
post subscribe subscribe like and
comment yeah
would it be annoying like every video
that's what somebody's got to put in the
front of it like and subscribe that's
what it is
and hit the notification comment too no
they say comment
oh yeah and plus hit the notification
what are you doing dude let me know in
the comments
yeah let me know in the comments they
always have some dumb thing to talk
about
yes you know most of the time yeah you
know i was thinking i was if you want to
see more videos like this go make let me
know in the comments
shut up bro what are you talking about
you know what you're
you're we'll just say i'm not gonna say
you're salty i'm not gonna say that
apparently you're salty but i'm that's
not what i'm saying the reason that you
feel
what i think that you're feeling right
now about that is because
it's like it's super obvious
like what they're doing they want to
like they want the intel for the
algorithm right the more
they want the engagement right obviously
they want the comments they want the
likes they want to because that's for
the algorithm so they can rate their
video higher so they can
and you we know that we know that we're
not even mad at that really kind of
but they're no but i think we or you are
mad quote unquote at the part where they
try to like
fake like that's not it they try to fake
like oh yeah you let me know all
you know you you're oh you know we're
talking to each other we're friends
almost
kind of a feeling and you're like bro
you don't want to know you don't want to
know what i
think you know that's what it feels like
i can't read the guy's mind so i don't
know if he really wants to know or not
but
that's how it feels that's why i feel it
too well i'm
i i don't say uh in the videos like
comment but i read the comments because
they're funny they are funny
and they're good and some of them are
interesting yeah it's true i've gotten
some
uh good tips on books to cover and stuff
from youtube comments literally that's
kind of crazy right
yeah so i'll read the comments because
they're interesting
they're funny yeah youtube
comments kind of have a reputation on
that kind of straight up
youtube comments have the rep the stigma
of being like a cesspool of just
like unreasonable negativity but i think
usually with our stuff it's they're they
can be constructive most of the time
i'm down yep so uh if you want to leave
a comment leave a comment
like subscribe smash
anyway yes the point is we do have a
youtube channel so if you want to look
at that boom there you go also
psychological warfare is an album that
jocko did i recorded back in the day for
the purpose of yeah very hard no
not man it was helpful it was very hard
you literally pressed record bro
yeah that's what recording is you press
record on the thing do you think
everybody's like super pumped on that
i think they're very impressed yeah
nonetheless okay
it was recorded for the purpose of
helping me through my moments
of weakness then we added some other
stuff about weaknesses that i don't have
but that other people might have
which turned out to be the case so yeah
if you have some moments of weakness you
want to listen to jocko telling you how
to
get over them boom psychological warfare
if you want to see a visual
representation of how to stay on the
path go to flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer his company he's putting
all stuff kind of cool stuff to hang on
your wall
good stuff and plus it's dakota meyer
which is just
well it's dakota meyer got some books
final spin
coming out soon well coming out november
is that soon
depending on when you're listening to
this so final spin
novel book poem transcript
what did you think you called it text
text the text literature
literature literature sure hell yeah
if you want that first a dish get on it
leadership strategy and tactics
the code the evaluation the protocol
this money was freedom field manual read
a little bit of that today
weigh the warrior kid one two and three
for your kids for your neighbors kids
just for every kid that you know get
them on the path when they're young
mikey and the dragons about faced by
hackworth which i wrote the forward to
extreme ownership of the dichotomy
leadership echelon front what do we do
at echelon front dave
we solve your problems to leadership
that's what we do what about problems
that
aren't leadership problems if i've said
it once i've said it a thousand times
all your problems are leadership
problems i stole that though
who'd you steal it from somebody
go to echelonfront.com if you need help
inside your company that's what we do
we have ef online.com where we
teach leadership principles online
this is your leadership gym that's where
you go in and get some sets get some
reps
yeah get it done break work up a little
leadership sweat
do some role playing ask some questions
we're there all the time we have a
a a conference that we put on i don't
know if that's the best word but we have
an event that we do
i don't even know if that's the right
word anyways there's a thing
you can come to which is called the
muster
we talk about leadership for two days we
do uh
activities come and check it out phoenix
august 17th and 18th las vegas
october 28th and 29th
we have something called the ftx coming
up
july 12th and 13th if you want to check
that out
it's tactical training with the emphasis
on leadership
and you can take the leadership
principles that we talk about all the
time and apply them in a tactical
environment which will then
you you will then be able to transfer to
whatever environment you're in
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization
and if you want to donate or you want to
get involved then go to
[Music]
americasmightywarriors.com.org
sorry and if you want to
hear
if you want to hear more of this of
my cringingly long
just reading of texts
if you want to hear echo charles
randomly ranting about god knows what
if you want to hear dave getting hyped
up on things that don't matter
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on the gram on facebook
echo is that echo charles dave is at
david r burke and i am at
jocko willink and to all of the
uniformed personnel out there in the
military
who take these strategies and put them
into action
to protect our way of life thank you for
what you do
and to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all
first responders
thank you for protecting our way of life
here at home
and everyone else out there remember
that napoleon
the the great military leader
napoleon bonaparte remember that he
pursued his vision of peace for 20 years
of war
and ended up defeated
and in exile don't do that
don't do that think strategic
adjust your ends to your means
make sure you can actually win
make sure you can see that pathway to
victory
make sure you can see those pathways
plural to victory and then start down
that path
and give it everything you got and until
next time
this is dave and echo and jocko
out